the barbell approach is like for a
portfolio Okay has your extreme risk has
your extreme negative risk and take
maximal positive risk
[Music]
how to make something robust
to make something robust
there are two things because of Jensen's
inequality is better to run better to
walk and Sprint
rather than just jog
so you have a strategies that are have
variations in them bipolar strategies
are vastly better than mono you know
strategies and you see it for example in
it was portfolios it's much better to
put 80 of your money risk-free if you
can find something like that and 20
speculative rather than uh the whole
thing medium risk much more robust that
way but you can see it in the policy of
every single monogamous species which
includes humans but but we know we have
data for Birds monogamous Birds
typically
instead of the female
opting for a good match she's she picks
the accountant
ninety percent of the time and the rock
star to cheat was 10 of the time
for a linear combination of having
someone in the middle you see
so the idea you take the loser of a
stable accountant and something like
another that accountants are losers but
you see the kind all right and and then
you take and then you have the Hotshot
rock star
on the occasion so the linear
combination is better this is explained
in the book why things that have
variation and I use the same the very
same equation of just as they call it
show why it's a lot more stable the
barbell approach is like for a portfolio
Okay has your extreme risk
you see has your extreme negative risk
and take maximal positive risk
I would say if you're looking at beating
the market so Alpha I don't do that in
hands-off styles of investing uh I I
have that very much on one side of my
barbell so I personally
partially by choice and partially by
Fate have ended up with a very uh
barbell looking asset distribution and
if you were to look at what I have
you're going to have highly volatile
what most people consider highly risky
class of Investments namely startups and
cryptocurrency that's going to be
more than 50 percent of my total assets
and then you have real estate and cash
or cash like equivalents and that's
pretty much it so on opposite ends of
the spectrum and we could debate whether
or not real estate is risky we could
debate the benefits of cash if uh you
also have to contend with inflation but
let's just keep it simple for the sake
of this this discussion and say that you
have
highly volatile
what most people would consider high
risk High reward categories like
privately held startups and
cryptocurrency on one end of the barbell
which is where I create my Alpha and
then you have real estate Cash Cash like
equivalents and things like for instance
Muni bonds and so on where you would
then preserve that Alpha okay so you
create Alpha take it off the table and
then preserve Alpha now
forget about the question of converting
crypto into Fiat or keeping it in crypto
let's just keep it simple so that is
currently what my say asset allocation
would look like that is very very likely
to change over time and I should address
a couple of questions that likely come
to mind one would be why on Earth do you
have more than 50 percent of your net
worth in startups in crypto
and it is not because I had a hundred
units of assets and decided to put 50
plus percent of those units into crypto
and startups that would be complete
Insanity I think for almost anyone it's
because I started off with a very
reasonable allocation some of you might
remember that many years ago 2008 or so
I created for myself a real world MBA
rather than going to a Stanford GSB or
one of these graduate school programs of
business I decided to take the same
amount of money over two years at that
point of sixty thousand dollars a year
for two years and invest that into the
Tim Ferriss Fund in quotation marks to
try my hand at startup investing in the
very beginning piggybacking and
co-investing with people who knew what
they were doing
and I assumed the network built the
skills developed the knowledge acquired
over that two-year period of time would
benefit me more than the 120 000 which I
assumed I would lose or the Assumption
was much like tuition that would be a
sunk cost and that then set me on this
accidental career of being an early
stage Tech angel investor and advisor
and that tiny sliver of my total pie
chart at that time due to uh lucky slash
good Investments and Company selection
has swollen to a gigantic percentage of
the total pie chart with companies like
uber Facebook Twitter Alibaba and so on
uh crypto very similarly uh has has not
uh necessarily risen as it would have
had I gone in early with something like
ethereum but has nonetheless doubled and
so on over time more than doubled so
compared if you look at my cost basis it
was a very rational well semi-rational
decision at the time at the time to
allocate what I allocated but due to
growth they now represent a very very
large percentage of my total Holdings
and the crypto can be freely traded the
startups are locked up all right so I am
unable to decrease my positions and
balance those uh for the most part
and that is why my portfolio looks the
way it does I would not recommend my
asset allocation to really anyone
reflections
how I personally think about investing
my money when I reflect on this I can
think of three different buckets where I
can invest my money bucket number one
invest in yourself the best investment
you can make is an investment in
yourself the more you learn the more you
will earn Warren Buffett this bucket is
all about growing your knowledge base
and skills by learning from other
people's experiences and discoveries it
can be very concrete knowledge that you
already know is going to be instantly
useful to you like for instance a
workshop on how to run Tick Tock ads and
also a more broad kind of knowledge like
for example learning from the life of
Charlie Monger or about mental models
and this can be very cheap because you
can mostly find it on the internet for
free or in books a platform that I
personally love using for this is short
form which is why I contacted them to
create a long-term Business Partnership
with picking nuggets I think most people
just go straight to the concrete
knowledge that they need but I think
it's also important to be exposed to
Broad Big Ideas because in words of
steep jobs you cannot connect the dots
looking forwards you can only connect
them looking backwards so as you expose
yourself to new ideas you become more
prepared and as you become more prepared
you will be able to see more
opportunities around you as a brand
Lincoln once said I will prepare and
Someday my chance will come I see this
bucket as kind of like a meta bucket
because improving your judgment by
learning from other people is a critical
component for attaining success in the
following two buckets
bucket number two build your own asset
this is the entrepreneurial bucket where
you take your interests creativity and
knowledge to build something from
scratch which will be successful if it's
useful for a group of people so in this
bucket you use the money to get the
things that you need to start your
entrepreneurial banter or make it grow
and the good thing is that nowadays is
not necessary to have a lot of money or
good connections to bootstrap your
business because you can freely access
to infinite leverage thanks to the
internet also I think that tinkering in
the internet is much more aligned with
the barbell model that we have seen
because in the internet mistakes won't
cost you any money or will be super
cheap and when you get something right
you can turn it into a highly profitable
business whereas in the case that you
are purely using Capital leverage your
mistakes can be very expensive as Mr
Beast commented in The Joe Rogan podcast
you only want to add the capital and
labor slowly as you are proven right
with your judgment the absolute best
resource that has helped me to learn the
general principles of today's
entrepreneurship is a three hour long
podcast episode of Navarro weekend on
how to get rich above I attach a link to
this episode bucket number three buy
other people's assets this is about
buying assets from other people that can
potentially maintain or increase in
value and the investment is a means for
passive income as you probably guessed
my currently favorite asset allocation
strategy for an investment portfolio
would be the barbell model there are two
things I love about the barbell the
obvious one the fact that I avoid the
risk of rain because 80 to 90 percent of
the funds would be in low risk asset
classes such as cash high grade treasury
bonds and real estate as legendary
investor Ray W says make sure that the
probability of the unacceptable I.E the
risk of Ruin is nil and the other thing
that I love is that for the 10 to 20
percent risky portion it's okay if I
don't calculate the risk with Precision
because the most I can lose it's that 10
to 20 percent whereas if I were to put
everything into medium risk I would have
to accurately estimate the risks and the
thing is that it's almost impossible to
do this because we all have blind spots
and we cannot predict the future
personally for my current circumstances
and object tips I mostly focus on bucket
one and two but I do have a barbell
extreme of around 15 percent of my
little net worth composed by a highly
volatile stocks and now I'm also open to
consider Equity ownership through
crowdfunding of private companies or
investing in the Fine Art Market which
has now been democratized Thanks to
companies like Masterworks which by the
way is kindly sponsoring this video also
I try following Ray dalio's advice on
that the Holy Grail of investing is to
have good diversification as it can
remove the idiosyncratic risk from your
Investment Portfolio but please do not
take any of these as investment advice
as it is made for entertainment purposes
only now I will expand a bit more on
this mathematical property of Jensen's
inequality so that you can get a clear
idea of how it works beware though that
I'm not any PhD mathematician just an
average engineer so please correct me in
the comments if you see anything
inconsistent as the physicist Richard
famous says if you want to master
something teach it so here we go for
Jensen's inequality to be valid the
function has to be convex we have two
variables geofix is the function of X
and it is a convex function and X is a
random variable having this into
consideration Jensen's inequality
establishes that the expected value of
the function of X is higher than or
equal to the function of the expected
value of x as a little side note the
expected value is nothing but the mean
or the weighted average let's illustrate
the concept we draw a convex line in the
two-dimensional space where the random
variable X is at the horizontal axis and
the function of X is at the vertical
axis now let's locate two points in the
x-axis X1 and X2 now if we consider that
these points have equal probability of
50 percent that means that the expected
value of x is going to be in the middle
of both points beware though that
Genesis and quality is valid for any
probability distribution but we take the
50 percent just for Simplicity now let's
take the function of that particular
point and this value will be the
function of the expected value of x now
let's do exactly the same but instead of
using the X points we will use the
function output of those X points so we
take the function of X1 and the function
of X2 then we can draw the linear
combination of both points and locate
the expected value at the middle that
will be the expected value of the
function of X as we can now see the
expected value of the function of X is
higher than the function of the expected
value of x if we now say that X
represents the risk level and the
function G represents a benefit we can
clearly see how for a same amount of
risk between risk 1 and risk 2. we will
always get that the benefit is higher
for the case of the bipolar strategy
because it creates a second line which
is always above the convex curve if you
want to know more about Jensen's
inequality I highly recommend you to
check the explanation link it above by
MIT professor John cesiclis now let's
close Jensen's with an insightful quote
from Nasim taleb just as stoicism is a
domestication not the elimination of
emotions so is the barbell a
domestication not the elimination of
uncertainty and now a quick word from
today's sponsor Masterworks right now
the ultra richer doubling their media
investment into one particular Market
Business Insider says demand has been
insane for the past decade but with
2022's volatility CNBC says the ultra
reach may see this investment as a hedge
against inflation and perhaps a safer
store of value than increasingly
volatile stocks and cryptocurrencies
what Market the Art Market but more
specifically the multi-million dollar
fine art as an investment its
appreciation outpaid is even the S P 500
for the last 26 years by 131 percent but
if you're not a billionaire don't worry
you can still diversify with art in an
SEC qualified way thanks to Masterworks
even as the stock market has fallen over
20 this year Masterworks sold a painting
for a 13.9 net return just a few weeks
ago that brings their last three sales
to 13 17 and 21 net returns to investors
and although past performance is not a
guarantee of future results it is pretty
impressive Masterworks has over 600 000
users and paintings have sold out in
minutes but you can use the link in the
description for pre-loaded Priority
Access thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign
[Music]